[Music]
on this saturday night
a doctor charged with first-degree
murder
the investigation into suspicious deaths
at an ontario hospital
we are looking at multiple recent
deaths at the facility what put police
on the trail of dr
brian nadler the end of operation honor
we need a fair process
that everyone can believe in why women
in the military say the system
failed them plus china fires back with
sanctions against a canadian
mp and will the courts have a say in
newfoundland and labrador's
election results
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us an ontario doctor has been charged
with
first degree murder dr brian nadler who
specializes in
internal medicine was working at a
hospital in hawkesbury
a town located between ottawa and
montreal police say the investigation is
far from over
they're looking into what they describe
as multiple
suspicious deaths and the scope of their
probe may extend across the country
and into the united states travis dunroj
has our top story tonight
i was kind of shocked when i heard the
news for eight days last month sebastian
fournier was a patient at this
hawkesbury hospital
he is still coming to terms with the
fact his lung therapist
someone he describes as professional and
funny is now charged with first degree
murder
the doctor i saw was a very passionate
about his work and
very attentive to his patient care dr
brian nadler was arrested thursday night
after officers were called to the
hospital to investigate a suspicious
death
ontario provincial police say they are
now looking into multiple suspicious
deaths
that's when the scope expanded and now
we are looking at
multiple recent deaths at the facility
so
it's still this is still a very new
investigation nadler received his degree
from mcgill university in montreal in
2010.
he went on to do a residency at the
university of alberta in edmonton
until 2014 then headed to saskatchewan
documents from that province's college
of physicians and surgeons
show he was charged with two counts of
unprofessional conduct
a report shows nadler used misogynistic
profanity
to describe an attending physician at a
saskatoon hospital
and said he felt like slapping her he
resigned from the residency program in
2018
ended up in reno nevada where he was
employed as a geriatric fellow at the
university there
he returned to canada and was licensed
last year in ontario
it's unclear when he started working at
the hospital in hawkesbury
well first off we can't speculate where
this is going to go right now we have
one person
accused of one charge of first degree
murder global news reached out to police
in nevada and saskatchewan to see if
they have been contacted by ontario
provincial police
we did not hear back before deadline
nadler's lawyer would only say this
dr nadler maintains his innocence
we will be defending him rigorously
fournier says news of the murder charge
has spread quickly in the small
community
but maintains the doctor gave him
excellent care
no i didn't see anything wrong with his
attitude or his
personality 35 year old nadler is also
licensed to practice in quebec but never
has
his next court appearance is scheduled
for april 6.
travis standradge global news toronto
we have exclusive details on the crisis
that has engulfed the canadian armed
forces and its leadership
the military has been grappling with
accusations of sexual misconduct among
its most senior ranks now the woman
making allegations against canada's
chief of the defense staff admiral art
mcdonald
is breaking her silence here's our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
i admire and respect her so much she was
the face of international women's day
for the canadian armed forces
navy lieutenant heather mcdonald a
16-year veteran of the military
a naval combat systems engineer
ensuring canada's warships are ready for
battle on the high seas
but mcdonald's time on one of those
ships has landed her at the center of
the storm
swirling around the canadian forces it's
been very isolating
very very isolating for me mcdonald says
she was duty-bound to report a
historical incident
she allegedly experienced involving
defense chief admiral art mcdonald
the incident allegedly occurred on a
ship docked off the coast of greenland
in 2010
mcdonald stepped aside from his role
last month just
weeks into the job after details leaked
revealing a military police
investigation
that investigation is still ongoing
multiple sources have told global news
it relates to an alleged sexual assault
mcdonald remembers how difficult it was
for her as a naval officer
to report the admiral the first to lead
canada's military in nearly 30 years
a sinking sensation in my stomach
it wasn't the best day it wasn't the
best day
as a woman in the male dominated trade
mcdonald says
she's had to deal with inappropriate
behavior throughout her naval career
but she says it was the notorious red
room incident a zoom call she attended
involving allegedly sexualized comments
made by senior naval officers
that triggered her to report the alleged
incident involving admiral mcdonald
the message that came across loud and
clear was operation honor applies to you
guys
doesn't apply to us and
it really bothered me that that could be
interpreted that way and that that
message
was coming across that way earlier this
week the acting chief of the defense
staff lieutenant general wayne ayer
pulled the plug on operation honor the
military's mission to stamp out sexual
misconduct from its ranks
ayers said the military will take stock
of operation honors lessons
and develop a plan to go forward
mcdonald says
she hopes her story will help bring
justice to other members who have been
harmed by their own
and that a fair process for trying
high-ranking officers
like the cds will be developed for other
victims
we have to stop hurting our people we
don't have so many people that we can
continue to do so
and we need a fair process that everyone
can believe in
global news has reached out to admiral
mcdonald for comment
but he did not respond robin mercedes
stephenson
in ottawa and you can see the full
interview with left
heather mcdonald tomorrow on the west
block right here on global
beijing is firing back slapping its own
sanctions on canadian politicians
it's in retaliation for ottawa imposing
penalties
on chinese officials foreign affairs
minister mark garneau called the move
unacceptable and an attack on
transparency and freedom of expression
the sanctions targeted the house of
commons subcommittee on international
human rights and singled out
conservative foreign affairs critic
michael chong in a tweet chong said
we've got a duty to call out china for
its crackdown in hong kong
and its genocide of uyghurs adding if
that means
china sanctions me i'll wear it as a
badge of honor
the sanctions prohibit chong and the
other members from entering china
including hong kong and macau
and from doing business with chinese
individuals or entities
this week canada joined the us uk and
european union
in imposing sanctions on four chinese
officials suspected of being responsible
for the persecution of uyghurs and other
muslim minorities
more than 10 weeks after the vote was
called the results are in for the
election in newfoundland and labrador
and the premier's gamble paid off andrew
fury has managed to secure a majority
while his two key opponents
lost their seats it was a unique
election and the way it was conducted
has never been seen in this country as
ross lord reports
all that maneuvering could end in a
court challenge
andrew fury gambled and won
preliminary results show fury's liberal
party of newfoundland and labrador
winning 22 of 40 seats in the province
boosting the liberals from a minority
government into a majority
it's an honor and privilege to stand
before you as our province's
14th premier to continue as premier is
to stand as a fighter
in a proud legacy of fighters for
newfoundland and labrador
both of fury's rivals lost their seats
pc leader chess crosby and ndp leader
allison coffin
both sidelined since the pandemic
started
fury is the fourth incumbent premier to
call an election
and increase his party's number of seats
it wasn't easy
after a covet-19 outbreak in the final
week of the campaign
staff at polling stations refused to
work elections planners switched to
mail-in voting
but a string of problems followed
elections nl admitted to allowing some
people to vote by telephone which
violated the elections act
some voters said they received too many
voting kits
others got no ballot leading to
extremely low turnout in some parts of
labrador
i never had any any uh
way to put my two cents
two cents worth and i never had a chance
to vote
and then there's a lot of them none not
translated for the older folks
so i don't know what the percentage up
here of the voters are going to be but
i'd say it's going to be really really
low
to some stormy weather on this makeshift
election day is appropriate because
the results are unstable now it's
possible he's stuck with
with some uncertainty with this election
even if they even if they have the most
seats it doesn't necessarily mean
that they will govern as a majority for
a long period with these results
especially if the election is challenged
in court but fury insists
he's not worried so you consider it a
fair election
and no question at all about the
validity and the mandate that you have
no
the controversy threatens to overshadow
a bleak reality
newfoundland and labrador is broke a
longtime
orthopedic surgeon fury hints fixing the
province's tattered finances will take
tough medicine
and bold thinking with lingering
questions about how he won
it's unclear whether people are ready to
move forward
ross lord global news halifax
next week canada is projected to hit 1
million cases of coven 19
and signs of a third wave are already
apparent today ontario reported more
than
2400 cases it's now been three days of
more than 2 000 cases in that province
and it's the worst single day increase
since january 22nd
quebec reported more than a thousand
cases in 24 hours
bc is also seeing a spring surge
with 908 new cases reported friday
it's the third highest daily total in
that province
since the start of the pandemic in the
u.s the vaccination campaign is going at
brick neck speed
about 3 million doses are administered
each day but cases are rising in half
the states
as jennifer johnson reports scientists
are trying to determine
whether people who have been vaccinated
can still get the virus
and spread it the head of the u.s
centers for disease control and
prevention is
urging americans to take precautions as
new cases and hospitalizations of covet
19
have risen over the last week i remain
deeply concerned about this trajectory
we have seen cases and hospital
admissions move from historic declines
to stagnations to increases but most
states are quickly reopening
there are nearly no restrictions anymore
in colorado arizona has lifted
its mass mandate and starting this
weekend bars and restaurants in north
carolina can once again serve alcohol
until 2 a.m
but tables have to be six feet apart
actually have increased staff and
increased
security and dormant to make sure that
there's a presence walking around to let
people know
we are just as excited as you are but we
still are not quite there yet
we still have rules that we're trying to
follow
restrictions have eased in maryland too
even though cases are rising
i know the president said he'd like to
see some return to some sort of normalcy
by the fourth of july but i'd like to
see it done by
memorial day millions of americans are
being vaccinated each day
i want to get back to see my family i
love traveling
but right now only about 15 percent of
the country is fully vaccinated
it's clear there is a case for optimism
but there is not a case for relaxation a
new study is being launched in the u.s
to find out just how effective
vaccinations are in stopping the
transmission of coven 19.
researchers will monitor vaccinated
college students and their close
contacts
at select universities we'll be able to
answer the very important question
about whether vaccinated people get
infected asymptomatically and if they do
do they transmit the infection to others
that study could be another key to
determining when american life can
finally get back to normal
jennifer johnson global news washington
a negative kova 19 test was the ticket
to a concert in spain
that's right a concert
five thousand people packed a barcelona
stadium to see the spanish band
love of lesbian in order to get in
ticket buyers had to take a rapid
antigen test
it's part of a study to see if same-day
covet screenings are effective in
preventing outbreaks at large events
face masks were also mandatory but there
was no social distancing
people with heart disease cancer and
those who recently had contact with an
infected person
were asked not to sign up
rallies were held today in alberta and
manitoba after recent attacks against
racialized communities in canada
the protests were peaceful and called
for an end to the violence against
minorities
black muslim women in alberta have
complained about a recent spike in
attacks
and asian communities say they've also
been targeted since the start of the
pandemic
still ahead the deadliest day in myanmar
since the military coup
and the protest in the uk over a new
policing law
this is the deadliest day in myanmar
since the military took over
soldiers shot and killed at least 114
people
many of them were unarmed civilians and
children but protesters refused to give
up
they returned to the streets in more
than a dozen cities demanding the return
of their democratically elected leader
aung san tsuchi in the capital the armed
forces held its annual holiday with a
parade
representatives from eight countries
attended including russia
and china the british government is
trying to push ahead with a contentious
bill that would give police new powers
to stop protests
ten people were arrested in the third
night of demonstrations
outside the police station in bristol it
began as a peaceful sit-down
protest but scuffles broke out when
officers tried to break up the crowd
critics of the proposed legislation
argue it infringes on the right to free
and peaceful expression
that has led to a protest movement known
as kill the bill
now to the saga in the suez canal the
ever given ship
is still stuck and still blocking a
vital shipping route
strong tides and winds continue to
complicate efforts to dislodge the ship
from thick
sediment the head of the canal authority
says it's looking to remove
some of over 18 thousand containers on
board to lighten its load
but only as a last resort the ship that
carries cargo between
asia and europe has been stuck in the
canal for five days now
still ahead how young people are giving
the power of poetry
a modern makeover
you're watching global national
hello right now this is the hottest
tourist attraction in iceland
hiking trails have been created for the
thousands of sightseers wanting to get a
glimpse of the fiery lava fountains
the volcano erupted a week ago for the
first time in 800 years
and experts say it could be like this
for years
poetry has exploded in popularity long
viewed as
stuffy and elitist the genre has
inspired a new era of young poets from
diverse backgrounds
and they don't shy from their personal
feelings i spoke with some young poets
across the country
about how the medium is getting a new
makeover
i was in ocean once bare shoulders and
whale song
in my rib cage i watched as the rigs
drilled holes in my body
nisha patel gets paid to write poems
they left no part of my trenches
unmanned rarely is this a career but
patel is edmonton's
poet laureate your job as a poet
laureate is to reflect the times
and the thoughts and the feelings of the
people does the city put any pressure on
you to write about them or
or write put them in a good light the
city has never once put pressure on me
to write about them in a positive way
and i'm happy to say that to this day i
probably haven't done that anyway
here's the proof in this recent attack
on city hall
the city wishes harder shoves body into
a convention center
and hopes the people with the votes are
appeased that no tax dollars have been
wasted
there's a new generation of young
diverse poets in canada
with a lot to say when i didn't have a
bible
my religion teacher called me devil's
daughter
i think there's just a hunger for poetry
because everybody
if you think about it like way back in
the day
poets were actually revered they were
respected
their poems are political personal and
go beyond the pages of a book check out
the full story tonight on the new
reality
at 7 pm feeding the front lines up next
a canadian entrepreneur thanks the
pandemics
unsung heroes
an ontario entrepreneur has found a way
to thank the healthcare workers
at long-term care homes since january
he's made sure hot meals get delivered
to the front lines
every single day and as karen lieberman
reports
this isn't the first time he's been
compelled to help
in the kitchen of this middle eastern
restaurant the team is hard at work
preparing
hot meals it's a meal of gratitude we
call it mohammed fakee is the founder
and ceo of canadian restaurant chain
paramount fine foods in toronto he's
known as much for his business sense
as he is for his social activism and
philanthropy
when i get impacted by something and i
feel it i react by doing something
fakie's focus right now long-term care
a sector hit hard by the covid 19
pandemic
3 700 seniors died in our community and
it was hurting me
you know i grew up in a community where
treating our seniors
says a lot about us fakie's story began
a world away
in beirut lebanon i have been in a war
i've lived in bunkers
and i always came out with a smile
because i believe there is a light that
will come
he came to canada with little more than
a dream
to be successful fakie succeeded and has
dedicated himself
to others from providing hotels for
those experiencing homelessness
to hiring syrian refugees thank you
thank you so much for all your hard work
and now feeding frontline long-term care
staff
to date 11 000 meals have been served
with multiple locations receiving every
day
the goal is 30 thousand meals but that
would depend on donations
[Music]
we don't get to see the appreciation
right firsthand so it's nice when
someone comes and and brings us all
lunch
for kathy mclennan this gesture of
goodwill
speaks volumes i mean it may be a little
thing
but it means so much to us because the
food for the ltc
frontline campaign is less about lunch
more about showing appreciation and
expressing gratitude
to everyone out there giving back feels
good feels amazing
and it does not maybe you i'm not
changing their life
but i'm sure we are making one day
better for them karen lieberman
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is alice siding in
creston bc
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
you